daily routine for nearly two months
she calls Social Services
non-governmental organizations and
shelters hoping someone will have news
of her nephew emir
eight days after the earthquakes the
body of emir's father was pulled from
the rubble of their home
five days later Cruz found his mother
and older brother hugging each other in
the remains of the stairwell
all that
but there has been no sign of
four-year-old emir
days have been like 45 years to us each
time the phone rings we get excited
thinking maybe this time Emir has been
found we've called everyone Social
Services NGS YouTubers and influencers
nothing's come from it
the Casas are living in a tent now they
are mentally and emotionally exhausted
we are finished says nurse
Emir is
more than a thousand people who have
gone missing or remain unidentified and
hundreds of them are buried in this
Cemetery debris with families say they
are suffering from the agonizing weight
but there is little they can't do
these lawyers from the hotel Bar
Association are helping some of the
families
we provide legal services for the
relatives of the missing people our
lawyers take the case to the
prosecutor's office which contacts the
hospitals and shelters to check whether
the missing person is still alive they
get DNA samples from the relatives to
see if it matches the DNA of the buried
people
according to official figures nearly 1
300 bodies have not been identified
and more than 300 people have been
declared missing
as emir's immediate relatives are dead
the authorities have taken DNA samples
from his grandparents which would be
harder to match
say they still hope to find Emir alive
but if not at least they will be able to
visit his grave
Southeastern turkey